hi everyone
welcome you all to our monthly nature of
inference colloquium series
and um as you all know this is a new
series that we have started at the
frankie program motivated by
a lot of my own work and those of you
who don't know me i'm priyana tarajan
i am an astrophysicist and i happen to
be the current director of the frankie
program in
science and the humanities at yale my
own work
is has been in trying to understand the
phenomenology of
black holes in the universe and a
persistent
issue that has nagged all the modeling
and conceptual work i do
is whether the correlations empirical
correlations that we actually see
between properties of
black holes and the galaxies that host
them and so on whether they actually
reflect
a causal physics or are they just
happens chance a consequence of some
kind of statistical
manifestation of the evolution of
structure formation so that sort of
seeded this interest but i've been so
fortunate
that as part of this series we have
invited very distinguished researchers
across disciplines who are working on
understanding the complex issues
of causal inference focusing on how we
draw robust conclusions from conceptual
models and simulations
so uh the series represents cutting-edge
researchers who are exploring various
kinds of uh
conceptual frameworks agent simulations
ab initio time evolution modeling of
complex nonlinear systems
propagation of genetic transcription and
expression climate modeling
um to distill the role that modeling
actually plays
in helping disentangle correlation and
causation
and so we are getting this we're going
to get this multi-disciplinary view
of how this is done it's a very
challenging problem
and it's a very fundamental problem in
epistemology across
intellectual disciplines this
distinction between causation and
correlation
so uh first let me thank um
uh mr um and mrs richard and barbara
frankie for the generous support
of the frankie program and all the other
activities at
yale that they have supported um they
plan
to join us uh uh today for our talk
and i also just want to remind you that
we are recording this event so i would
uh
request you all to mute your videos and
ask for questions after this afternoon's
talk up
we would like you to submit them through
the chat feature
and uh either our um i or
uh professor um
um we don't expect professor i to be
watching the chat so
it would be either dr cam for i who
would be reading out the chat questions
and our format will be as per usual
after his talk we'll have a q a
afterwards and um i also want to remind
you
that a part of the series we have a
follow-up detailed discussion
and q a the following day after the talk
and uh professor i has kindly agreed to
do that tomorrow again at the same time
3 p.m
and that will be a conversation between
him and
professor kyle kramer who is a physicist
who is working also
on applications of machine learning and
ai techniques to big data
in physics so really looking forward to
that exciting conversation
as well so let me first introduce
our distinguished speaker today uh
professor i is an honorary professor at
the max planck institute for mathematics
in the sciences at leipzig and has a
joint appointment at the santa fe
institute
uh he studied mathematics and physics at
rural university and received his phd
from the university of leipzig um in
2003 and for he was a postdoctoral
fellow at the santa fe institute
and at the redwood neuroscience
institute
uh which is at berkeley and after his
postdoctoral time
in the us he became an assistant
professor at the mathematical institute
at
frederick alexandra universities in
london
and since september 2005 he's been a
group leader at the max planck institute
for mathematics in the sciences
where he is currently heading the group
on information theory of cognitive
systems
as a professor of santa fe institute
he's involved in research on complexity
and robustness theory
and since december 13 he also has an
honorary professor of information
geometry that's a very intriguing title
at leipzig and he is um
looks like he's going to actually be
moving very soon
to the hamburg university of technology
where he's going to be spearheading and
building up an entirely new institute
the institute of data science
foundations as part of their technology
and innovation center for
hamburg so uh professor i today will
start by providing
us an introduction to the field of
causal networks
and will then focus on giving us some
simple examples to drive home and
highlight the core conceptual and
philosophical ideas that underlie this
theory
and he has a very novel approach that
will show us how this kind of new
language that he has developed that will
allow us to distinguish
between causation and correlation and
he's also going to
teach us that this allows us to study
how cause and effect relations
will give rise to a very particular kind
of correlations
and they can be exploited to infer
causal relations in turn
from the observed correlation so you can
imagine that i am particularly excited
because i think it's going to be very
very relevant
for my own personal research agenda
but i'm sure that you will all be
excited to hear
and learn from him today so without
further ado um
i would like to um invite you to start
thank you so much for agreeing to speak
in our series
yeah thank you very much for inviting me
and giving me this opportunity
um let me
share my screen so thank you again
as i uh wrote in one of my emails my
my presentation is going to be a little
bit technical but
my intention is actually to
highlight the core structures of causal
networks
and the main
philosophical reasoning there and
um i want to make the point as a
as an introduction i want to make this
point how far we can get actually with
the mathematical formal structure of uh
causation so this is the outline of my
presentation i know i i'm not going to
have enough time to go through all these
subjects
in detail but i think i will
try to communicate the main main points
so let's start with the
causal with the structure of causal
networks
so the main building block of a
causal network is the notion of a
mechanism
and the mechanism is
[Music]
basically the idea is that you have a
function so it's mathematical
object f of x y is f of x
and then you allow for disturbances of
that function
so this is the disturbance u often you
have a model
where y equals f of x plus some
disturbance so that would be some kind
of additive noise it can be
multiplicative noise
but this version of it is much more
general so the function itself depends
on the
input x and the disturbance u so that's
the most general
way to write down a um
a mechanism a deterministic mechanism
and that actually has been already
considered
in genetics in econometrics social
sciences
information theory and so on so the idea
is that
the disturbance it's actually not
observable so what you observe
is the x and the y so let me
okay basically you integrate out the
disturbance
and as outcome y uh
you get you get a distribution of points
for
each point here is generated by by one
disturbance
small u so if you integrate out this
the disturbance u you get for each input
x a distribution of y's
formally this after integrating out the
disturbance you get a mathematical
object that is called
markov kernel sometimes you call it
stochastic matrix
or stochastic map so the basic
requirement here is that
for each x you have a distribution on
the y's
that's all so it means that kappa of x
y is greater than or equal to zero
because that's the probability
and the sum over the y's or the integral
over the y
should be one that's all so that's the
definition of a markov of a so-called
markov kernel
and that's the basic object a
basic mathematical object that is used
in order to model a mechanism
the mechanism in the context of causal
networks
is given in terms of a markov kernel or
stochastic map
as i said this has been used in many
contexts
and with the same you can do the same
construction here in the context of
of quantum mechanics and there you end
up with the so-called completely
positive map
which is frequently used in quantum
information theory
so that's the building block now the
question is how to put together these
mechanisms
the structure that describes how to
combine these mechanisms is a directed
acyclic graph so basically
it's uh as shown here
so you have the nodes these are the
variables a b
c u uh u does not
is not the disturbance here it's one
variable
and so basically
the the semantics here is whenever you
have an
arrow for example from a to b a is the
direct cause of b b is the effect direct
effect of a
and you also require that the course
always comes before
the effect okay that was the subject of
the previous presentation
so uh the uh the order has to be
first first the cause and then the
effect and that excludes
cycles like this this is the the reason
why we have to assume
that the underlying structure is given
in terms of a directed acyclic
graph so some people actually question
this
this assumption here but it's it's
crucial
so we have in the context of
uh once given such a graph you can talk
about the parents of a node v
denoted by pa so which
are simply those nodes that point to
v then the descendants
of you these are those uh notes that can
be reached by
uh from you the non-descendants and the
ancestors
so basically it's it's clear from the
from the naming here what it means
so now we have the the graphical
structure
in my first slide i explained what we
mean by a mechanism and now we have to
put these two structures
together so we we
we start with a directed basically graph
that's the structure
and then we we assume that for each node
we have given such a markov kernel and
a mechanism which basically is nothing
than a stochastic map so it takes the
inputs for example in x4 here
that node takes these as inputs
and generates a distribution over x4
so you have a mechanism in all all nodes
here
the only node
that does not get any input is x1 so
that's simply a probability distribution
over x1
but all the others have mechanisms
sitting
in them so and as i explained
whenever we have a directed arrow here
um we we refer to v as being the direct
cause of w
and w being the direct cause of v
and if i have such this curly
arrow that means that there's a path
from
v to w so that's
uh in that case i simply talk about
cause and effect without
uh without
referring to uh to it being
uh directed uh direct cause
so this is a simple example uh taken
from judea pearl's
book uh it's a quite famous book here
where the foundations of course networks
are
developed and so i'm not going to into
the details here but
with these with these uh
this kind kind of basic network you can
actually
describe a causal structure
or cause an interaction of of variables
so this is a more complicated these are
more complicated networks
um than uh the previous ones uh which
are more like toy examples and these
networks are taken from uh
also famous book um
uh by by leading experts of uh of the
field by lao
lauritzen and uh david
who uh and spiegel had allowed since
actually one of the
uh most famous people in graphical
models theory
so this kind of of graphic
representations of causal structures
then i added actually this slide here so
i was
i had long conversation with my daughter
today and tried to figure out which
movies to take here
which somehow tried to violate this idea
of directed acyclic graph so you have
time travels where you have loops
between
the uh past and the future so there are
people
and in these movies actually people try
to justify even such
loops uh physically um
in this uh this this uh movie here
groundhog day was actually presented uh
by the santa fe institute
many years ago and it was commented by
murray gelman
who actually uh discovered the quarks
and
uh he he was asked whether this makes
physical sense
to the ideas to go to start again
a new day every day uh to start again
and try to improve
so you go back after after you spend the
whole day you go back to the beginning
of the day and try to improve your
behavior
and at the end of the day of these
iterations you even become an expert in
piano playing even if you are not an
expert in the beginning so you really
have these loops
and which allow you to to improve here
and again so it was actually
uh stated by gelman that
this is physically a reasonable um idea
and uh the same with the other movies so
in this last movie here tenet
they even tried to uh to build the whole
story
uh based on the second law of
thermodynamics which was
as we have seen in the in the last
presentation
is a basic argument uh on
explaining the direction the direction
of time
okay let me go to the second
topic so now once we have the causal
structure here
the causal network we can define how the
mechanisms
which are part of this network
[Music]
generate the phenomena so how they
generate actually a distribution
so basically it's a simple rule you you
start
you have a numbering of the nodes which
which is compatible with that structure
so here the numbering is you start with
u
then a then b then c and then
you basically apply the mechanisms
uh according to this numbering so you
choose
u according to the probability
distribution phi of u
so it doesn't have any parents here then
you choose
a so this according to the distribution
of
a given u so this is a markov kernel and
then you iterate
okay so these are the mechanisms
uh note that i did not use the letter p
here really in order to refer make a
distinction between a mechanism and the
probability distribution
so the right hand side is basically a
combination of mechanisms
and it describes how the uh the
probability distribution
uh that uh uh of the
of the uh of joint events
on the full full set so the distribution
the probability of u
a b c is exactly given in terms of these
mechanisms
so i want to highlight here that the
left hand side is basically describing
the phenomenology
and the right hand side is describing
the mechanisms
and this equation is giving you a rule
how to generate
the phenomena based on the mechanism the
mechanisms
now we can ask the question once we know
the
the phenomena
the joint distribution can we actually
infer
the mechanisms based on this this
phenomena
and the answer is we can we can try and
the p
the way people try it is in in the
following way
so they take the distribution the joint
distribution so this is the observed
distribution
and then you can actually test
conditional independence statements
so if this distribution is generated by
mechanisms that are compatible with this
graph then it has to satisfy
this condition independence these two
conditioning dependence statements
so u is independent stochastically
independent
of b given a and
c is independent of a given u and b
so these are the two conditional
independent statements
that follow from this structure here so
if you take the
the joint distribution and do these
tests you will actually
you will be able to verify this
and the question is
do we recover the underlying structure
only by testing this and the the
the answer is no we don't because there
are many more
graphs directed basically grass that
satisfy the same
set of condition independence statements
okay
in this case so that's that's this graph
here
but you can also change modify this
graph a bit
and it will give you the same set of
conditional independence statements
and this is actually referred to as
markov
equivalence so all three graphs will be
markov equivalent in the sense that they
will give you the same
condition independence statements so
once you have generated with the
mechanisms the joint distributions so
the phenomenon
uh once you have reached the phenomenal
phenomenological
uh level you cannot go back to the to
the mechanism
simply by observing and testing the
condition independence statements
so and there's a there is um a whole
uh the the theory is well developed that
describes
actually the equivalence
markov equivalence classes of of grass
so it's a well-known
theory i i'm going to skip this and
continue with section number three
so the intention of uh this uh the mark
of
my present presentation of markov
equivalence is to show you that
just observing the system is not enough
so you can observe but you will not be
able to recover the
uh the full underlying structure
simply by observation so this is why
pearl actually introduces the notion of
intervention so you have to be able to
intervene into the
system and this is a second kind of
experiment so experimental operation if
you wish
one experimental operation is
observation and the second one we are
going to talk
about now is intervention
and i'm going to define intervention i
have to refer to the previous
uh presentation intervention was also
mentioned several times
especially when stating that the future
can be influenced through intervention
but not the past
so that was that that can actually be
verified within this
uh setting here
so let me define uh intervention
so let's say uh let's assume that this
is the
the causal the causal um
network so we have a directed ac graph
and we have the mechanisms alpha beta
gamma
and we want to intervene in a
and then observe b so what does this
mean
um so intervention in a means of
following
if we if we consider the full joint
distribution according to the original
mechanisms alpha beta and gamma it will
be given
according to this formula that's the
formula that i have just
uh discussed
so now you could observe the conditional
probability of b
given a that using standard
probability theory but intervention
means something different
intervention means changing the
mechanism
so in this product structure here we
have in
a we have the mechanism alpha alpha
takes
input from u and generates a
distribution
of small a's according to
alpha okay that's the markov kernel
sitting in
a now if we intervene in
a let's say we want to set the
the state of a to a head
then that means that we decouple
basically we change the mechanism of a
by replacing it
by alpha head and alpha head is simply
a very special markov kernel which is
one
it gives the distribution one
so the probability of a is one if a
equals a hat
and 0 otherwise so this is nothing but
saying that we set the state of a
to a head that's it and
in order to stay with my previous for
formal description i need to define a
markov kernel and that's the way i do it
here
formally it simply means changing the
mechanism
to a constant value a head
and now instead of this product
structure here we have a new
product structure so that's the we get
the new
causal network
but now the mechanism in a is changed to
a head
alpha head from alpha to alpha head so
phi remains the same
beta remains the same gamma remains the
same and alpha is replaced
by alpha head and that's it that's the
post-interventional distribution
now let's uh consider
so what i have shown to you here is the
post interventional joint distribution
after imposing a head now i want to
marginalize
out u b and c just to
know the post intervention distribution
over
b imposing a
so that means so that's the thing we
want to
compute so what hap what do we see in b
if we impose a hat so that's basically
marginalizing out all the others u
and c uh
so we take this post intervention
distribution
that i have derived previously and
marginalize out
and that has the product structure and
then we can go through the calculation
and you get
p of b as the result of
of the intervention so that means
that the effect of
of intervening in a is simply
so if i intervene in a and set the state
to a head
i will observe b with the original
probability p
of b the important thing to note here is
that
b that probability distribution is not
dependent on
a head so it's different from it
this is really something that you don't
get with uh
with uh classical conditioning so with
classical conditioning
the conditional probability of b given a
so as shown here will be actually
dependent on
a but when you intuitively you will you
would not
because there's no arrow here you would
not expect any effect in b
if you intervene in a because there is
no path from a to b
and this is exactly what you get here so
as a result of intervention you get
simply the distribution of b
with no dependence on a head
so this reflects our intuition that
there is no path from a to b
okay i just had a quick question so we
are still
talking about deterministic systems
right
so that there isn't when we say there's
no path
between from a to b do you mean that
there is a very suppressed
probability for a path from a to b
or there really is no path from a there
is no
no path from a to b so that's that's the
that's the assumption here so the
underlying the structure of
it is a directed acyclic graph
and uh some of the edges are simply not
there so
that means there's no causal if no
possibility
it's it's like the future causing
influencing the past right intuitively
would say there is no possibility
even no low probability okay
so that is independent of whether the
system is classical or quantum
right so the quantum version of this i
uh
it's it's not is not very well developed
so i'm i'm
i was referring to quantum setting in
the context of a mechanism so each of
these
pro factors here are uh
markov kernels and in the quantum
setting this would be completely
positive
maps but the theory of cause and
networks is not well developed
in in the quantum setting
so but the notion of a mechanism is has
an analog in the quantum setting
thank you you are welcome
so um yeah so we have the post
intervention distribution here and it
really is different from the usual
conditioning
p of b uh given observing
a head but now let's do the same thing
now intervening in u and observing c
so we can do the same calculation here
as a similar calculation so p of c
imposing u hat
and if you go through it this time it
turns out
that it's the same post interventional
distribution
that you get if you if you condition
according to the classical
conditional distribution so that's
that's the classical version of it would
be
p of c comma u hat divided by p
of u hat that's the classical version of
it and we have seen here that it's not
the same
but in this case it is the same so the
do operator
the intervention operator is
exactly the same in this example as the
classical
conditioning operator okay
uh and that has a reason actually so you
can
sometimes as we see sometimes the uh
the intervention gives you the
post-intervention distribution is the
same as the
uh or interventional conditioning is the
same as classical conditioning
and sometimes it's not and let me just
summarize here
so how we how we what we just did
or maybe i can just skip this so there
is a general
general uh formula for
for computing the post-interventional
distribution but i'll skip this
so here's here's the answer when the
intervention intervention conditioning
gives you the same as the observational
condition
so the do means we intervene in
a and observe b and that's the
distribution over the
the over b
imposing in a and that's the conditional
distribution
and they are the same if and only if
uh there is uh b is
uh so
so they are the same if b is not a cause
of a
and there is no common cause of a and b
and you can read it out structurally
so for example if we look at a and b
so the b is not the cause of a because
there's no path from b
to a so that's satisfied and there is no
common cause of a and b so there is no
u uh node pointing to a
and b so if we revert this direction
then there would be a common cause here
so if this is satisfied so this
condition is satisfied
then the interventional conditioning is
the same as the observation conditioning
but if we look at c and b
there is a common cause of i'm sorry c
yeah b and c yeah b and c so c
is not the cause of of b so the first
requirement is met but there's a common
cause of b and c
it's this one so we have u which is
with a directed path from u to b and the
directed path from u to c
so there's a common cause of b and c and
in that case
we cannot expect the the intervention to
be the same as
observation okay and the same with uh
with this uh
with this case uh the causal effect of
a on c we have a common cause on a and c
so again we don't have equality so this
characterizes
exactly the situations where
intervention differs from observation
but intervention gives us more and now
comes
now comes a really important thing that
notion the notion of identifiability of
causal effects
so let me let me
motivate this a little bit so we know
intervention gives us more some
information sometimes more information
than just
observing the system this is what i
tried to
to uh to demonstrate here
but often i mean if we know all the
mechanisms i have shown you the formula
for the intervention you could simply
compute
the post interventional distribution but
that's that's uh
that doesn't help us much because we do
the intervention in order to get
the mechanisms so that's the chicken egg
problem okay
so we don't know all the mechanisms so
that we can actually
uh compute the post interventional
distributions
so on the other hand in experiments so
in experimental intervention setting
we we take a system a natural system and
we do intervene into the into the system
experimentally so we don't do the
computation so what will
happen but we simply test it so we do
the intervention
and observe the system and see if there
is any effect
so that's the experimental intervention
but this of course we cannot do i mean
sometimes there are ethical problems you
cannot intervene into the brain of a
person that's simply not possible okay
so this is like a you know that you can
get get more information out of the
system if you intervened experimentally
but sometimes it's simply not possible
so the question now and the deep
question is
can we predict the outcome of
intervention even without
actually intervening into the system
simply by observing it
and that's that's that's the the
question of identifiability of causal
effects
and the answer is sometimes we can
and here's an example i have two
examples
so one is actually um
i refer to it as the back door example
and the next one will be the front door
example these are typical examples which
you can
study in pearl's book so if you
intervene in b
and observe c so we do the same
calculation that we did before
so the marginalization steps then you
have the joint distribution
and the joint distribution you can
replace by the mechanisms
and then do the calculation here and
then you end up with this formula here
and the nice thing about it is the
following on the left hand side
you have the do operation so which scene
which which basically says if you
intervene in p
you will if you did this if you do this
experimentally you will observe
this distribution on c
but if you don't do it experimentally
you can simply
go through this calculation and read out
this equation this
uh expression here so this expression
basic
can be completely computed based on the
joint distribution of
a b and c so this is simply p of
a comma b comma c divided by p
of a comma b and this is p of a
so that's all computable by simply
observing the joint distribution a b
and c and that's somewhat confusing but
yeah so it basically suggests that
you can replace the actual intervention
here
by observation by the information that
you
get in terms of of observing the system
but you have to change somehow the the
formula
so it's not just p of c
uh given b in the classical setting
so that would if you condition a here if
you write
p of a given b
here instead of p of a then you will end
up with
p of c given b in the classical way
but this formula is so to say different
from the classical formula
but it this equation tells you that you
can actually predict
the post uh post interventional
distribution based on observations
so in this setting in the terminology of
perl we can say
that the causal effect of b
on c is identifiable
by the joint distribution a b and c
okay so we we don't really intervene
into the system
we simply observe and then we can
compute
what we what would happen if we
intervened into the system
so that's the philosophical uh um
thought here
so for example we can use it in the in
this in this setting so i tried to
draw a large network here so it's of
course not huge but
it's
enough to demonstrate the point here so
if you have
such a network and you want to intervene
in v
and observe w okay so
what is the causal effect of v on w
so you could of course if you knew all
the mechanisms you could you could
compute this
as i have demonstrated but this we don't
have
so the question is and if you just
observe the joint distribution of v and
w you can compute the conditional
distribution of v
of w given v but the the
vector criterion tells us so this
formula tells us that we can actually
compute
what would happen in w
if we intervened in v by just observing
v w and in addition to that the parents
of v
so you see it so the the the uh
the causal effect of the post
interventional distribution on w
imposing x v
on the left hand side so that's an
interventional concept
can be written as something which is
computable based on observations only
so by observing v w
and the parents of v no matter what the
surrounding is of this system and how
huge it is it doesn't matter you only
need the disjoint distribution of
v w and the parents and then you will be
able to
predict the outcome of intervention
without intervening
so in other words if you if you take the
brain
and you you can you could if you knew
the parents of
each uh of of a particular neuron
you could actually predict the effect of
that neuron
on some other region in the brain simply
based on this joint distribution
so there's a question honey how this is
uh
i just wanted to kind of you know check
or clarify that the
you know the the part on the left where
you actually make the intervention of
course you could do that
experimentally and then just see what
happens the part on the right is
is the result that you get uh but that's
assuming that the
the causal diagram right i just wanted
to kind of
because the the language you're using
kind of sounds like you could
avoid doing the the intervention and you
can just compute it from the joint
distribution
but i think but you yeah yeah so that's
the
case you're making that assumption right
yeah so that's a very good point
uh i'm actually not that's partly true
and it's it's actually a very good point
so some so you could
think that in order to make this to to
have this equation
uh you you need you need to assume uh
so to say to know uh the structure of
the underlying the underlying structure
of the network
the point i want to make here is that we
don't need that
actually no matter how this surrounding
network
is you don't need any information about
this
the only information that you need but
that might be even too much
is what are the parents of v
so only knowing the joint distribution
so you
you do not need to know the parents of v
so which is in this case just i and j in
the setting of
of neurons of course you have like 1000
or 10 000 neurons
uh connected to to one particular neuron
so you would have to record all the
parents
but um the brain is of course much more
so you you so the point i want to make
is that local information
related to v is enough in order to
predict
the outcome of intervention
in v um with respect to w
no matter what what structure is around
that uh that triple here
so that you don't need more information
you need some part of it
that's i think the benefit of it so it
is really a full
it's really a full chicken egg problem
if you would assume
to know the whole network but the main
point here is that you don't
need to know the whole network but you
do need to to know
something about the network does that
answer
yeah i agree i just and this conditional
on the right
would you consider that local
information it seems like and the
picture you know w and v
are quite distinct but i agree it's
certainly not knowing the whole network
it's a
you it's a much smaller amount of
information you need to know
yeah that's much smaller so i've of
course
in my drawing i wanted to highlight how
small it is so i have just two parents
here
uh two notes as parents but
sometimes it is feasible you could you
could the record from the parents and
the node itself
so the so you have to record from the
parents of v and
so this is the joint distribution that
you need here and if you don't
have access to that there is no way to
compute it okay
but it's much much less than knowing the
full
joint distribution yeah great thank you
you're welcome so that's that's uh one
thing
that's the backdoor criterion and the
frontal criterion is
somewhat surprising more surprising
if if you had this this network here
let's say
so the way i think about it is so i have
let's say these are like intrinsic
observations of us of a system
intrinsic variables of a system and then
you have a you
is a huge the the huge environment let's
say
and uh so it's acting on
a and c so this is this is a common
cause of a and c
and it seems that there is no way to
actually compute the
to to predict the effect of
intervention in a on c without having
the full information here so let's say
an agent is really restricted to
observing a
b and c and then it's affected by by u
and the only requirement that you have
here is that this intermediate
variable is not affected by the
environment so just
a and c but the way it's set up here is
to actually demonstrate that it could be
quite counter-intuitive so
in this case i wouldn't expect to be
able to compute the
effect of intervention in a and
on c based on object based on just
observing a b and c but it turns out
that if you go through the computation
it's it's uh here's a trick you have to
uh you have to use some condition
dependent statements here
but then you end up with something
so the interesting part is this so you
start with something that takes into
account the mechanism of you
this huge environment let's say or
surrounding
world you have this mechanism that has
this you
you you everywhere and suddenly in this
last line
u cancels out and there's no u anymore
and this simply just uses condition
independent statements that are
compatible
follow from this causal structure here
so this says that if you
observe just a b and c
let's call them intrinsic variables you
you can predict the
the effect of of intervention in a on c
without actually intervening into the
system and that's that's
to me it's quite surprising it's more
surprising than even the
the front the the backdoor criteria
just as a um
as an application so we did apply this
to um in the robotics context
so uh coming back to maybe one comment
here i started with directed acyclic
graphs
often of course like in neural networks
or in
ages interacting with with the world we
have cycles
but the way we interpret them are
that is by unfolding them in time
so you get this directed acyclic graph
which
represents the world and the the the
brain of the agent
interacting with the world through
sensing and
uh and acting okay and
we actually simulate this kind of uh
uh of uh sensory motor loop in in the
context
of uh agents that you create within the
setting of
virtual robotics so this is uh
um uh kind of uh creature that we for
example analyze
and then an interesting question would
be here and that relates also to the
previous talk to the notion of agency
so what is what is the
we could ask what is the causal effect
of the actions
so this basically summarizes the for the
whole
past the history to one variable
h and reduces so to say
the whole sensor the whole causal
diagram of the
sensory motor loop to this small simpler
one
so now you can ask what is the causal
effect of a on the next of the actions
of the next sensory input
and when we started this i was
uh and and we we thought okay we have
this mechanism of the world
which is even in a simulation like this
it you cannot deal with it it has too
many states you don't
and that's basically what the physics
engine alpha is basically implemented in
within the physics engine and then you
have the sensors
so there is no way to compute it by
incorporating
alpha and beta but then we realize
actually we don't need that
so if you study it carefully the the
causal effect
of the actions on the sensors
is identifiable
intrinsically by the agent by just
measuring the joint distribution of its
brain state c
its actuator states a and the next
sensor states
so the left hand side is interventional
in nature and the right hand side is
observational
and that's simply by by the backdoor
criteria
and you can actually use the frontal
criterion to compute the causal effect
of your brain
on the next sensor state again we have
an interventional
thing here interventional uh
notion on the left-hand side and
observational notion here so we could
let the robot simply
run and do something and it will record
a joint distribution and then predict
its causal effects on the next sensor
input
so the the shortcoming here
and i want to highlight this all these
equations
are based on the assumption that the
probability distributions are strictly
positive
pearl is assuming this and
identifiability of causal effects
always starts with this assumption in
robotics settings
we have functional dependencies and this
this assumption is not meant this is why
we are actually working on
generalizations of this kind of
of identifiability so that's just
one one application
let me come maybe so how much time
do i have left you could
go for another uh five to ten minutes if
you wanted to
okay let me highlight the common cause
principle because i think this is really
really important so we have seen that
observation is not enough so we have to
intervene sometimes in order to get the
structure out of the system
and then if we cannot intervene we can
actually
identify sometimes the causal effect
even without
actual intervention by so-called virtual
intervention
replacing the the intervention by
observation
but that as uh pointed out correctly
that requires some additional
information about the underlying
structure like
knowing the parents for example you
don't have to know everything but
you have to know something and sometimes
you even don't know that so you know
don't know anything
and this is why i got interested in the
common cause principle even without
knowing anything you can't
say something about the underlying uh
causal structure
and that brings me to the to the common
cause principle so let me first uh
introduce what how we model
uh how we quantify stochastic dependence
so basically i i really like this
information geometric quantification
so stochastic dependence basically
compares a joint distribution
of variables from the product of the
marginals
okay and you have independence if this
equals this here so if you have equality
this is a one so this becomes one and
logarithm of one is zero
so the whole thing becomes zero so
basically
a stochastic dependence is the distance
from independence and by distance i mean
the coolback lipo distance or coolback
lipo divergence which is this quantity
here
so and here's a visualization so this
manifold here
this surface is basically denoting the
set of all distributions that have
product structure and
dependence is simple dependence of a
joint distribution
p in a joint distribution p is
quantified as
distance from independence and this
distance is referred to as
multi-information
and in this case where you have two
variables
so n equals two it's simply the mutual
information
so that's a nice geometric
interpretation of stochastic dependence
so now i want to present the quite
strong theorem
that we derived but for that i need to
introduce the notion of a common cause
so let's say we have a network and we
have observed variables here denoted by
uh in green here highlighted in green so
these are the
observed variables and we have some
surrounding
causal network and
ac denotes the
set of elements in the network
in the full network that reach at least
c observed variables
okay for example a2
is this so this is denoted by red
dots here red nodes so all the red ones
reach at least two observed
variables for example this one reaches
this
and this okay
this one is reached uh
reaches also two it reaches this
observed one
but it also reaches itself by a path of
length
zero that's an important point here and
we refer to this as the set of common
ancestors
so that's this a stands for ancestors
and the important point here is that
when you observe the joint distribution
so you have n
observed variables and
you you basically quantify
their correlation in this way h
denotes the entropy so you take the sum
of marginal entropies
and subtract c times the
the joint entropy so for c
equals 1 it's simply this this quantity
here
for c equals 1 is simply the
multi-information
so that will be greater than or equal to
zero anyway for c equals one
but so the the theorem that we could
that we could actually grow inequality
that we could prove is the following
you can upper bound lower bound the
entropy of the common ancestors
of degree c plus one by
this quantity here quantity of
correlation
only on the of the observed variables
so again the right hand side is
something that can be computed
based on the observed variables the
left-hand side
really requires the full surrounding
network
and it has it's the entropy of the
common ancestors
so which means that if you observe n
variables and you
quantif you you evaluate this quantity
and it it turns out to be positive
then you can infer that there is at
least
one common ancestor
of at least c plus one observed
variables
so you can infer the existence of common
ancestors of observed variables
because otherwise it's not possible to
explain the correlation
of the observed variables here's an
example
the famous reichenbach common cause
principle
if you just plug in c equals one here
it tells you basically that's a
corollary of the this general theorem
if two observed variables are dependent
then uh so these are the two variables
then there must be a path from one to
two
a path from two to one or there must be
a common cause
of both of them so that's a simple
implication of the
more general theorem that we have here's
another example
if you have variables
that are completely correlate maximally
correlated
then you cannot explain then there must
be
a common cause of all of them
so that's the implication so this kind
of correlation complete correlation can
only be achieved by a common cause
or common ancestor that reaches all
observed nodes this already excludes for
example if you compare these networks
you can say this is possible because
this reaches
all of them and here it's also reached
this one
this is also possible but these two are
not possible so you could exclude
potential explanations of the data
simply based on the correlation
structure of the nodes
and here again by this kind of test
you if you compare the sum of
of the shannon entropies with the global
shannon entropy then this doesn't tell
you anything so all three cases are
possible
if this is the left-hand side is greater
than the right-hand side
then only case one and two is possible
and
if even the margin the sum of the
marginal entropies is greater than two
times the joint entropy
then you can say this cannot be
explained by this or this test to be
this one
that's that's the uh uh the the strength
of this theorem
uh i'm maybe one final remark i'm not
going to talk about knockouts anymore
uh but uh just to uh
refer to this so we continued studying
this this result
which i'm really proud of so it has been
published
it has been derived by my former student
bastian steudle
based on my previous work and we could
show in this paper that it's a sharp
bound so you cannot get better that's
that's highlighted in this paper but in
a more recent paper
we could show that in most
generically so when you sample
networks so to say according to jeffries
prior
then most networks will not be will not
allow you to infer common courses so
it's a so it is sharp
in the sense that there exist situations
where you
where you reach this upper bound where
you have equality
instead of inequality uh but these
regions where you have this
are very tiny in the space of all
possible
causal networks so that that's the
downside of it
and um yeah i think i
i'll stop here and if there is interest
i cut maybe tomorrow i could say more
about knockout interventions
but let me let me stop here
due to the time constraints
hey um thank you so much um
this was uh very very intriguing i
have a lot of questions myself so i will
just go ahead and start with one
and share the floor with everyone else
so i think um i really think
this uh the last set of ideas the common
cause principle that you showed is
really really powerful and that is what
i can see as something that i can
actually apply
when i'm thinking about the kinds of
systems that i'm looking at
but you know i wonder what happens if we
have
incomplete information on the maximally
correlated variable so you know there
are x1 to xn that are
in fact maximally correlated but we only
know about
say n minus one of them or n minus two
of them
then then how do we work things out
because that is often the case in
astrophysics so one of the the problems
we have is we don't actually know
if we when we make observations and you
see two quantities that are correlated
with each other
what we don't know is whether this is a
mere projection
of a higher dimensional correlation
between larger number of variables
or it is actually just a true contained
correlation
only between these two variables
yes so that's a very good question
so this theorem does not require
completeness
so it's really so you observe
so you you you you know it's not
complete so there is this huge world
outside and you are observing n
variables so
n could be n minus one you have the
joint distribution of these
n minus one uh variables and you
consider the
the uh correlation structure of the n
minus one variables and you can infer
common ancestors or common causes
of uh these n minus one variables
okay so that's uh it's not required that
you know
uh the only requirement here is that you
assume that your physic
the system that you you the underlying
observation
can be described in terms of a causal
network that's the underlying
assumption here if it can't then
you can't use this inequality here to
infer
to infer common causes but
this also relates to uh to another
question that
uh so of course you could take if you
have the marginal distribution of n
variables
uh you could you could consider all
marginals of
of these n variables and you could
compute these quantities
and we have therefore the marginals and
you could try to get
out more information about uh about the
underlying network
in the lab larger network
and it's not clear to me uh
i think you can get out more information
than just uh considering the quantity
for the n variables
and similarly if i uh if the correlation
structure assuming as you said that it's
valid and you can represent it by a
causal network
so suppose there are in fact n variables
but that
i have um access
only to a sparser sub sample
yeah that's a very good question uh so
throughout my my uh
whole presentation i did not address the
issue of
of statistics
so that's of course a deep problem and
then a deep deep question
uh how to so all i did is starting with
the joint distribution assuming that we
know the joint
distribution clearly if we don't if you
only have data like the empirical
distribution
generated by the mechanisms we have
first to
to infer the the joint distribution and
then
apply this inequality so
um that's that's something that i
haven't worked on yet but it's a very
important
problem so basically inferring
common causes based on empirical
data distributions that would be that
would be the the core problem here
and of course associated with it the
generalization
aspects like statistical learning theory
and so on
and um then one final question which is
um and in in these in these causal
networks
are you making the assumption that you
know the mechanism already that you have
prior information
or it's the mechanism that you're going
to infer
right it's the details of the mechanism
that are part of the inference i want to
know where the mechanism
sits in this sort of landscape
yeah so you basically it's a button
so i started the whole thing by in a
kind of bottom-up approach so starting
with the
with the with the basic components
so you have the structure the directed
basically graph
and in each node you start with the
mechanism which is a markov kernel
and then the the question is the uh what
what are the interesting top-down
problems so you have the observations
and what are the
questions that you could ask and one
question that you could ask what is the
underlying structure or what is the
mechanism and so on
and in order to get them so you i don't
i don't assume
to know them i only assume that they
exist
and then i could aim to uh reveal them
through observation or through
intervention and this is definitely
possible in terms of intervention right
so i think this is the other thing that
i wanted a slight clarity on
the sort of differentiation between an
observation and an
intervention
um what i mean is um so if you can use
the sensory motor example that you had
of that little crawling creature
so uh how how would you separate i'm
trying to map it on to problems in
physics so i'm trying because you know
their
observation and uh intervention
have very particular definitions and i'm
trying to see if they map on to the same
definitions
so the intervention would be something
like you know
if you perform a controlled experiment
it would be a repetition for example
right would be would that be an
intervention or would that be an
observation i'm a little
confused about the separation between
what is an observation and what's an
intervention
so basically if you refer to this agent
uh
perceiving and acting in a world so it's
doing something it's functioning
and an intervention would require
actually to set for example if you want
to quantify the
call to get the causal effect of its
brain
on its next sensor input by definition
it would require
somebody from outside setting its brain
to one state
right and then observing uh the next
sensory input
so like uh something from outside but
that's of course a thought experiment
the question is that you cannot do
but then the question is is it possible
to get
the same results so the effect uh
of the brain state on the next sensory
input
based on just observing the system
without any intervention from outside
and this is the message is yes it is
it's possible ah
okay but you have to change the formula
so it's very simple i mean it's very
simple the question is whether you can
apply this maybe i can share this slide
here
yeah so this is this is for example
so so that would be the somebody from
outside
i see controlling the actions right
and then observing what the outcome on
on on the sensors
so and that that would be the left hand
side but you can forget about this if
you can measure the joint distribution
of
c a and s the so the
by replacing this so you can remove
get rid of the external
intervenor so to say external agent
by just using the formula on the right
hand side
and if you want to compare this with the
with the classical uh conditioning
you would have to so if you just replace
p of c
by p of c given
a b of c
given a then you get exactly
p of s given a without the do operator
simply by uh
the the usual formula for conditional
probabilities
so it's almost almost almost the the
same but there is one important
difference
in this conditioning here so if you
remove that conditioning on
a you get exactly the post intervention
distribution
but that has that has it's it's not
yeah it's not clear that you can
actually apply this
because this requires counter factual
situations so that you actually can
compute the conditional distribution um
in situations where
um so this has to be defined in other
words yeah i was just gonna say that
needs definition right yeah yeah
yeah so that that's that that has to be
defined and of course
if the probability of c comma a
is zero you don't know what this is and
then the
this equality breaks down so that's the
downside of it
so it is a nice
thought and it might be applicable in in
some settings in our settings
setting we did not we did apply it but
we did not
get very far with it because of this
counter counterfactuals here
so uh one has to extend
the identifiability problem to
situations
with uh zero probe with um
to situations where the distribution is
not strictly positive
great so i want to invite mark gerstein
who's a
bioinformatics expert to uh ask his
question
sure uh i had a question i think it was
on your slide
on the identifiability of causal effects
i think that was where
we had another question um and you know
this
i was just curious could just to get
some intuition about the formula you
have there
can you just explain what happened in
the complicated network if say
there was only one path between v and w
or if there was no paths between v and w
just you know just to get some intuition
how that formula would
be affected by that uh
so so if you
just as one example because all arrows
go from
v to w here right
so there's no path from w to v
oh no no i'm saying so so there's many
paths now
i think that's related to the question
you got earlier so there's many paths
now
that you can kind of track they're
indirect from v to w right you can just
yeah what if there was no path you could
you could not
follow the direct and there was no pass
or there was just
one single path what what would that do
to your your
how would that manifest itself in your
equation so
if there is
no path then the outcome of this
will be simply p of x
w without any conditioning here
because if there is no path
then the outcome of w will not depend on
any intervention here because there is
no path
so no matter what kind of w uh of state
uh you have in in v this will not have
any influence on w
okay sure so that will be p of x v and
that's that's
something that's something reasonable
if there is one path uh i th
there will be no no difference no
special uh
change of this formula and it will not
it will not uh
it will not uh simplify maybe maybe
it's easier to it's it will be easier to
prove this
equality here if you had only one path
if you write it down with one path
you will be able to prove this equality
maybe
more easily oh okay okay
great um thanks um i think there is
another question now from
agastya rana and his question is
could you provide some intuition as to
why the
identifiability of causal effects here
only depends on the parents of we
and not on all of the ancestors yes this
is an excellent
question that i was also curious about
um it the the thing the
the reason for that is that you have a
condition independence statement so the
uh
the uh
basically uh in any in any uh
directed acyclic graph so in any
bayesian network
the um a node is
independent of its non-descendants
in particular independent of its
ancestors
given its direct
causes which are the parents
so you have always for each node each
node is independent of its
non-descendants
given its direct causes and
that's that's the so-called local uh
markov
uh property which basically means if you
know your
your parents the state of your parents
you don't need to know more
any additional information about your
ancestors or even non-descendants
will not help you to to to predict any
uh
uh will not improve your predictions
right so you're just
it's sufficient to go just one layer
deep in exactly exactly
that will be the uh the main reason for
that
so um i guess um i'll wait to see if
there any other questions meanwhile um
i have one so i was um curious about
what about the structure of a causal
network
predicates predictability
right you can predict like outcomes of
uh say time ever if i'm looking at a
system and i want to understand the time
evolution
and if i um assume that i can actually
model it as a causal network and that it
satisfies
all these conditions that we've been
talking about then
is it maximally predictable can you
then make predictions how does
predictability of future states
of the system assuming you can figure
out the mechanism and so on right so
is that connected to no
not really i mean there is so the thing
is that
the causal network is really
coupled with conditional independence
so the structure is is
so there is a one-to-one correspondence
between the structure the graph
and condition dependence statements uh
and in the context of of a dynamical
system for example you can
if you represent it in this way you can
say the
the future is conditionally independent
of the past given the present
okay this is something that you can say
conditional
predictability is i think
more about dependence as opposed to
independence so being independent or
conditionally dependent does not mean
that the mutual information
is high so the mutual information
between the past
let's stick with this example the past
and the future
can be uh can so the the amount of
information that you can extract from
the past in order to predict the future
can be low even though uh
um so that's an additional requirement
so it's independent of the assumption
that the past and the future are
conditionally independent given the
present so you can't keep this
this condition independent statements
past and future
being conditionally independent given
the present and tune the predictability
up
by increasing the mutual information and
tune it down
for example in an iid setting
you do have conditional independence but
there is no predictability at all
so the mutual information is zero right
yeah so that you can so that it is tuned
by
the amount of mutual um information
exactly exactly exactly that will depend
of course on the mechanisms right yeah
great um let me just quickly check if uh
there are any more questions
um doesn't look like there are any
uh typed into the chat so i want to take
this
opportunity to remind everyone that
we'll have a more detailed conversation
and discussion
of the concepts that were discussed in
today's talk um
tomorrow at the same time at 3 p.m and
the conversation will be
where between nihat and kyle cranmer
and we're really looking forward to it
and thank you so much for
your uh talk this evening and look
forward to seeing you tomorrow
yeah sorry about the time difference so
it's kind of a late
um um
late time for you uh in germany but
that's that's so that's okay thank you
very much okay thank you
bye-bye see you tomorrow yeah see you
all tomorrow
bye everyone thank you and see